under secretary general for political
and peace building affairs to
participate in this meeting
which is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
and i'll give the floor to ms resume
thank you
mr president
it's with great concern and sadness that
i briefed the council this evening on
the unfolding dangerous situation in and
around ukraine
in his statement today
the secretary general was clear the
secretary general considers the decision
of the russian federation to recognize
the independence of certain areas of the
donetsk and luhansk regions
to be a violation of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of the united nations
we very much regret this decision
which risks having regional and global
repercussions
we also regret the order to deploy
russian troops into eastern ukraine
reportedly on a peacekeeping mission
these developments follow the decision
to order a mass evacuation of civilian
residents of donetsk and luhansk into
the russian federation
we are concerned by the escalating
shelling across the contact line
reportedly leading to a number of
casualties
osce's special monitoring mission has
recorded a total of 3231
ceasefire violations in the dumbass area
from 18 to 20 february 1073
ceasefire violations including 926
explosions in the luhansk region and
2158
ceasefire violations including 1100
explosions in donetsk region
remind we remind all involved of their
responsibilities under international
humanitarian law and human rights law
although the united nations is not in a
position to verify the numerous claims
and allegations made by various actors
we are deeply concerned about the
reports of civilian casualties targeting
of civilian infrastructure and ongoing
evacuations
mr president we are extremely concerned
about the possible implications of the
latest developments for the existing
negotiation frameworks
amid the current risks and uncertainty
it is even more important to pursue
dialogue
negotiation is the only way to address
the existing differences among the key
actors regarding regional security
issues
and the settlement of the conflict in
eastern ukraine in accordance with
security council resolution
2202
before the current already dangerous
conditions escalate further
we call on all relevant actors to focus
their efforts on immediate secession of
hostilities
civilians and civilian infrastructure
must be protected and actions and
statements that may worsen the situation
must be avoided
over the past few weeks key actors have
been engaged in intense diplomatic
efforts to avert a new eruption of
conflict in the heart of europe
the secretary general
fully supports these efforts
and has deplored even the possibility
that a new conflict could break out
mr president we are committed to our
long-term partnership with ukraine a
founding member of the united nations as
it continues to pursue the democratic
reform agenda 30 years after
independence
and once again we reiterate the full
commitment of the united nations to the
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity of ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
according to general assembly
resolutions
throughout the eight years of conflict
in eastern ukraine the united nations
has continued to provide
life-saving humanitarian support
to all in need as well as human rights
related work
during this difficult period we are
committed to stay and deliver and remain
fully operational in ukraine
including in the donetsk and luhansk
regions
the safety and security of our staff
must be respected by all parties
mr president the next hours and days
will be critical
the risk of major conflict is real and
needs to be prevented at all costs
i can assure you of the full commitment
of the secretary general to work toward
a diplomatic resolution of the current
crisis thank you mr president
i thank mr carlo for her briefing
to those council members
who wish to make statements
to the permanent representative of the
united states
thank you mr president
since world war ii the united nations
charter the key tenets of which this
council is mandated to uphold
has stood as a ball work to the worst
impulses of empires and autocrats
earlier today russia's president
vladimir putin announced that russia
will recognize as independent states
the so-called dpr and lpr regions the
sovereign territory of ukraine an area
controlled by russia's proxy since 2014.
he has since announced that he will
place russian troops in these regions
he calls them peacekeepers
this is nonsense
we know what they really are
in doing so he has put before the world
a choice
we must meet the moment and we must not
look away
history tells us that looking the other
way in the face of such hostility
will be a far more costly path
russia's clear attack on ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity is
unprovoked
it is an attack on ukraine's status as a
u.n member state
it violates a basic principle of
international law and it defies our
charter
what is more this move by president
putin is clearly the basis for russia's
attempt to create a pretext for a
further invasion of ukraine
the consequences of this action will be
felt far beyond ukraine's borders
we do not have to guess at president
putin's motives
today president putin made a series of
outrageous false claims about ukraine
aimed at creating a pretext for war
and immediately thereafter announced
russian troops are entering the donbas
he claimed that ukraine is seeking
nuclear weapons from the west this is
not true
ukraine is in fact one of only four
countries to have voluntarily
surrendered their nuclear weapons the
united states and our allies have no
intention of sublime supplying nuclear
weapons to ukraine and ukraine doesn't
want them
and then president putin asserted that
russia today has a rightful claim to all
territories
all territories from the russian empire
the same russian empire from before the
soviet union from over a hundred years
ago
that includes all of ukraine
it includes finland
it includes belarus and georgia and
maldova
kazakhstan kyrgyzstan and tajikistan
turkmenistan uzbekistan and lithuania
latvia and estonia it includes parts of
poland and turkey
in essence putin wants the world to
travel back in time
to a time before the united nations to a
time when empires rule the world
but the rest of the world has moved
forward
it is not 1919
it is
2022.
the united nations was founded on the
principle of decolonization
not recolonization and we believe the
vast majority of u.n member states and
the un security council are committed to
moving forward
not going back in time
the consequences of russia's actions
will be dire across ukraine across
europe and across the globe
in our past two meetings on ukraine i've
mentioned nearly 3 million ukrainians
will need food shelter and life-saving
assistance right now
the u.n estimates the humanitarian toll
will expand significantly should russia
further invade
already russian proxies dramatically
increased shelling and artillery fire
over the weekend killing ukrainian
civilians and soldiers
if russia invades ukraine even further
we will see a devastating loss of life
unimaginable suffering millions of
displaced people will create a refugee
crisis across europe
nevertheless russia has declined
repeated entreaties to status intentions
before the world including by secretary
blinken in the security council last
thursday
colleagues president putin is testing
our international system
he is testing our resolve and seeing
just how far he can push us all
he wants to demonstrate that through
force he can make a farce of the u.n
we must act together in response to this
crisis over the past few weeks the world
has heard the other 14 members of the
security council speak with one voice
asking russia to pursue diplomacy
other members of this council even those
who often align with russia on other
matters have been clear that the
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity of every u.n member state
should be respected and safeguarded
including ukraine
that this is a basic norm of
international relations and that it
embodies the purpose of the u.n charter
the sequence of events that secretary
lincoln spelled out for this council
last thursday appeared to be proceeding
exactly as he predicted
today president putin has torn the mask
agreement to shreds
we have been clear that we do not
believe he will stop at that
in light of president putin's latest
actions we must all stand up for the
principles upon which this organization
was founded
president biden
issued an executive order today that
will prohibit new investment
trade and financing in the so-called dpr
and lpr regions
tomorrow the united states will take
further measures to hold russia
accountable for this clear violation of
international law and ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
but we and our partners have been clear
that there will be a swift and severe
response for russia to further invade
ukraine
in this moment
no one can stand on the sidelines we
must make it clear that an attack on
ukraine is an attack on the sovereignty
of every u.n member state and the u.n
charter and that it will be met with
swift and severe consequences
we continue to believe that the
diplomatic table
is the only place where responsible
nations resolve their differences that
is the only place to preserve peace
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
states
for their statement
give the floor to the permanent
representative albania
thank you mr president
let me thank you as gd carlo for another
clear and comprehensive briefing to the
security council on this issue
albania condemns in the strongest terms
russia's decision to recognize
non-government-controlled areas of
ukraine as independent entities
this is a breach of international law
an affront to the u.n charter
another blatant violation of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and it puts an end to the minsk
agreements
this act of the russian federation is
null and void has no basis and has no
international legal validity
we call on the security council and all
the united nations member states to
reject and condemn it firmly
albania reiterates its firm position in
support of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
mr president less than a week ago we
were sitting in this very room at the
russian initiative to discuss the
implementation of the mins agreements
today
we meet an at an emergency meeting
exactly because of the russian
federation decision to violate the very
minsk agreements
this is a disrespect not only to the
council and its decisions
but for the entire universal principles
of international law
russia is set to respect and protect
the whole world has witnessed how the
russian federation has continuously
worked to undermine the sovereignty of
ukraine and to determine its
geopolitical orientation
what happened today is nothing less but
a biz repetitor of what we have seen in
georgia in 2008 and with crimea in 2014
meaning
an aggression by fabrication of phantom
republics
who is next
every un member state should be alarmed
and realized
eyes wide open
the consequences of instrumentalization
of national minorities as a weapon to
undermine sovereign states
threaten regional and international
peace and security
we should not accept the made in russia
model of destabilization be exported to
other parts of europe or anywhere else
there
we reach rate our demand for the removal
of the military troops from the
ukrainian border and from the occupied
territories of ukraine including troops
disguised as peacekeepers when they are
simply aggressors
albania calls on the russian federation
to stop its very complete policy
revoke its illegal decision and engage
seriously and in good faith with
diplomatic talks and give a chance to
the minsk agreements
dear colleagues
this is yet another critical moment for
ukraine
the u.n should remain actively engaged
and committed together with regional
organizations to the right of the
ukraine people to live in peace and
freedom
we welcome the statement of the
secretary general and echo his call for
all relevant actors to prioritize
diplomacy
to address all issues pacefully as the
only way to move forward and i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement i now give the floor
to the permanent representative of
france
mr president president
i would like to thank the usg for
political and peace building affairs
[Music]
request for an emergency
which were confirmed at the very highest
level these last few days
on the 17th
legal basis to solve the conflict
but today the reality is quite different
russia is choosing
the path of confrontation
in spite of the incessantly
we are continuing these
in the context of the heightened
tensions on ukraine's borders
provoked
the threat that that weighs on european
security
france
welcomes the rest restraint
that ukraine has shown in these
difficult circumstances we express our
full solidarity with the people and the
government of ukraine
we call on russia to refrain from any
other actions of destabilization
notably those that
may
undermine the security of the safety of
civilian populations and put them in
danger
we are particularly concerned by the
decision of president putin
to send the army to the separatist
territories under the pretext of
peacekeeping
this would be another flagrant violation
of ukraine's territorial integrity
president
france will continue to mobilize in
support of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders thank you
i thank the representative of france i
now give the floor to the representative
of india
thank you
mr president
let me begin by thanking under secretary
general rosemary de carlo for her
briefing
we have been closely following the
evolving developments relating to
ukraine
including developments along the eastern
border of ukraine and the related
announcement by the russian federation
the escalation of tension along the
border of ukraine with the russian
federation
is a matter of deep
concern these developments have the
potential to undermine peace and
security of the region
we call for restraint on all sides
the immediate priority is de-escalation
of tensions
taking into account the legitimate
security interests of all countries and
aimed towards securing long-term peace
and stability in the region and beyond
we are convinced that this issue can
only be resolved through diplomatic
dialogue we need to give space to the
recent initiatives undertaken by parties
which seek to diffuse tensions
in this context we welcome the intense
efforts underway including through the
trilateral contact group and under the
normandy format
we need parties to exert greater efforts
to bridge divergent interests
we cannot afford to have a military
escalation
as we have emphasized before the mints
agreements provide a basis for a
negotiated and peaceful settlement
and we need greater efforts to find
common ground to facilitate the
implementation of the provisions of the
minsk agreements including key security
and political aspects
as we have time and again emphasize
constructive diplomacy is the need of
the art to avoid scaling up of tensions
the safety and security of civilians are
essential
more than twenty 000 indian students and
national live and study in different
parts of ukraine including in its border
areas
the well-being of indian nationals is a
priority to us
in conclusion we strongly emphasize the
vital need for all sides to maintain
international peace and security by
exercising the utmost restraint and
intensifying diplomatic efforts to
ensure that a mutually amicable solution
is arrived at the earliest i thank
you yeah
i thank the representative of india for
his statement i give the floor to the
permanent representative of brazil
thank you very much mr president
let me start by thanking usg rosemary
dicarlo for the updates she has brought
to the council tonight
mr president when this organization was
established in 1945
it entrusted the security council
with the primary responsibility for the
maintenance of international peace and
security
tension in and around ukraine
is being aggravated on a daily
indeed hourly basis
making this habitual quotation from the
charter of extraordinary importance and
relevance
we are all aware how critical the
situation has become
brazil is following the latest
developments with extreme concern
in the present circumstance
we in this council
in representation of the international
community
must reiterate calls for immediate
de-escalation
and our steadfast commitment in support
of political and diplomatic efforts to
create the conditions for a peaceful
solution
to the crisis
the collective security system of the
united nations
rests ultimately on the pillar of
international law
this in its turn
rests upon core principles enshrined in
the charter
the sovereign equality and the
territorial integrity of member states
the restraint in the use or in the
threat of use of force
and the peaceful settlement of disputes
yet this pillar and principles will not
yield results
unless legitimate concerns of all
parties are taken into consideration
and unless there is full respect
for the charter and for existing
commitments such as the minsk agreements
in this vein
we renew our appeal to all concerned
parties to maintain dialogue in a spirit
of openness understanding flexibility
and a sense of urgency to find ways for
a lasting peace in ukraine and in the
wider region
a first inescapable objective is an
immediate ceasefire
with a comprehensive disengagement of
troops and military equipment on the
ground
such a military
disengagement will be an important step
to build trust among the parties to
strengthen diplomacy and to seek a
sustainable solution for the crisis
we firmly believe that this council must
live up to its core responsibility
to help the parties engage in a
meaningful and effective dialogue so as
to achieve a solution that effectively
addresses the security concerns within
the region
make no mistake
at the end of the day
we are talking about the lives of
innocent men
women and children on the ground i thank
you mr president
i thank the representative of brazil for
his statement
and i'll give the floor to the
representative the permanent
representative of the united kingdom
mr president
we meet this evening
because earlier today president putin
announced the russian federation's
recognition
of the independence of the so-called
donetsk people's republic and lukansk
people's republic
and issued a decree
to send russian military forces
into ukraine
as so-called
peacekeepers
colleagues
the actions russia has chosen today
will have severe and far-reaching
consequences
first
to human life
an invasion of ukraine
unleashes the forces of war
death and destruction
on the people of ukraine
the humanitarian impact
will be terrible
on civilians fleeing the fighting
we know
that women and children
will suffer most
second
to the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of a un member state
which is protected
and guaranteed
by the un charter
as the secretary general said earlier
russia's decisions
are a violation
of the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent
with the principles of the un charter
third
to international law
the actions taken today
make mockery
of the commitments russia has made
through the budapest memorandum
and the minsk agreements
endorsed by security council resolution
2202
in seeking to redraw borders by force
russia's actions
show blatant contempt
for international law
the united kingdom will be announcing
new sanctions on russia
in response to its breach of
international law
and attack on ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
there will be severe economic
consequences to its actions
colleagues
now
more than ever
the council must shoulder its
responsibilities
for peace
and security and defend the principles
of the international the u n charter
the council must be united
in calling on russia
to de-escalate immediately
in condemning aggression against a
sovereign nation
and defending the territorial integrity
of ukraine
in calling on russia
to respect its obligations under the
charter
to the peaceful resolution of disputes
russia has brought us to the brink
we urge russia to step back
i thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement i now give the
floor to the representative of mexico
senior president
for the briefing by the usg on the
current situation in ukraine
we are following with concern the recent
developments in the situation in the
east of ukraine
in these circumstances it is critical
that those actions exacerbating this
crisis cease
the security council through resolution
2202
supported a range of measures as the
only way to resolve the situation in the
east of ukraine
this resolution must be respected
specifically in this particular case
three fundamental principles of the un
charter are being violated
refraining from threatening to use or
using force in international relations
respect for the territorial integrity
and political independence of states
and non-intervention in the internal
affairs of states
it is therefore unacceptable that over
the last few days
the shellings explosions and other
ceasefire violations have increased
according to reports from the osce
monitoring mission
we urge the parties
to immediately
end these actions
we wish to recall that in this same room
a few days ago
russia made a categorical statement
saying
that they would not invade ukraine
we hope that they will comply fully with
that statement
mexico reiterates its commitment to the
respect for the sovereignty
political independence and the
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
pursuant to the united nations charter
international law
and the relevant resolutions of the un
security council and general assembly
particularly resolutions 26 25
and 33 14. we once again reiterate our
appeal
to resume the path of de-escalation
diplomacy and dialogue thank you very
much
i thank the representative of mexico for
her statement
i give the floor to the permanent
representative of ireland
thank you mr president and i also want
to thank under secretary general de
carlo for her briefing
mr president we meet tonight at a moment
of great danger for the people of
ukraine
for peace and security in europe
and for the international norms and
principles that all of us around this
table have a responsibility to defend
it's a moment we had hoped to avoid
a moment that should have been averted
by diplomacy and dialogue
we must respond to it by speaking
clearly and honestly about this grave
situation
and how we can resolve it peacefully
so let me be clear about where we stand
ireland's commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
is unwavering
ireland believes in and is fully
committed to the core principles
enshrined in the un charter
these include the sovereign equality and
territorial integrity of states
ukraine has the same fundamental right
as every other sovereign and independent
state to choose its own foreign policy
and to ensure the security and defense
of its own territory
the commitments we make as members of
the un are binding on every one of us
no exceptions
mr president last thursday during the
meeting organized by the russian
federation on the minsk agreements we
heard from deputy minister version
that the goal of that meeting was for
the security council to affirm
that there was no alternative to this
milestone document
we believe that the council did just
that
yet now four days later president putin
has decided to recognize as independent
entities the non-government-controlled
areas of donetsk and luhansk and to
order troops into those two regions of
ukraine
this is the second time in less than 10
years that the russian federation has
violated ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
it is a flagrant violation of
international law
in taking this unilateral step
russia has abandoned the minsk
agreements and cast into doubt all the
diplomatic efforts of past weeks
ireland commends ukraine for the
restraint it has shown in the face of
russia's military buildup at its border
and the provocation of the recognition
of the donetsk and luhansk regions
ireland along with our eu partners
supports a clear and unequivocal
response to this violation of ukraine's
sovereignty
the russian federation's unilateral
actions serve only to further raise
tensions
ireland once again calls for calm
de-escalation and the pursuit of
diplomacy
even if that call has not yet been heard
it's a call worth making again tonight
we need to see sustained and credible
moves on the ground toward de-escalation
of this crisis
we urge russia to reverse the
recognition withdraw its military forces
and return to discussions within the
normandy format
mr president all signatories of the
minsk agreements agreed on the need for
the osce's special monitoring mission
safe and secure access to the entire
territory of ukraine
the mandate of the smm was agreed by all
57 osce participating states
at this sensitive time it is imperative
that the smm be given the full access
agreed in its mandate
we commend those who have engaged in
dialogue and urge them
to redouble their efforts to seek a
peaceful resolution
to this perilous situation
we owe nothing less to the people of
ukraine
we call on all parties to ensure the
protection of civilians as well as
refraining from any actions
that would escalate the situation
mr president ukraine has already endured
eight years of bitter conflict with over
fourteen thousand lives lost
the people of eastern ukraine in
particular have suffered from years of
insecurity humanitarian crisis and human
rights violations and abuses
this council and its members have the
responsibility to work to resolve this
conflict rather than yield to a grim new
chapter which will inflict further
misery on ukraine and its people
this is the time to show the courage to
pull back from the precipice and return
to dialogue and diplomacy
mr president we all need to demonstrate
our faith in the value of diplomacy
tonight thank you
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement
and i'll give the floor to the permanent
representative of the united arab
emirates
thank you mr president and at the outset
i'd like to thank under secretary
general for political and peace building
affairs miss rosemary de carlo for her
updates and briefing this evening
and i'd like to refer to the statement
that the uae delivered in this chamber
on 17 february on the same subject
i'd like to emphasize once again the
importance of de-escalation and
restraint
to maintain regional and international
security and stability
we believe now is the time to
engage constructively and in good faith
to address the current situation and
mitigate its impact of course on any
civilians and civilian infrastructure
and to chart a diplomatic path forward
mr president the uae reiterates the
importance of dialogue as others have
said de-escalation diplomacy and to
continue all efforts to reach a peaceful
solution consistent with international
law and the charter of the united
nations particularly the principles of
territorial integrity independence
sovereignty and good neighborliness and
we believe uh the minsk agreements form
a good basis for that
and that adherence to these principles
is indeed a sustainable
pillar of a peaceful pathway forward and
i thank you
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates for her statement
i give the floor to the permanent
representative of kenya
thank you mr president i thank under
secretary general rosemary dicarlo for
her briefing
we meet tonight
on the brink of a major conflict in
ukraine
the diplomacy we urged on the 17th of
february
is failing
the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
stands breached
the charter of the united nations
continues to wilt
under the relentless assault of the
powerful
in one moment it is invoked with
reverence
by the very same countries who then
turned their backs on it
in pursuit of objectives
diametrically opposed to international
peace and security
in the last two meetings on the
situation in ukraine
and the buildup of forces by the russian
federation
kenya urged that diplomacy be given a
chance
our cry was not heeded
and more importantly
the charters demand for states to settle
their international disputes by peaceful
means in such a manner that
international peace and security and
justice are not endangered
has been profoundly undermined
today
the threat or use of force against the
territorial integrity
and political independence of ukraine
has been affected
kenya is gravely concerned by the
announcement made by the russian
federation to recognize donetsk and
luhansk regions of ukraine as
independent states
in our considered view this action and
announcement breaches the territorial
integrity of
ukraine
we do not deny that there may be serious
security concerns in these regions
but they cannot justify today's
recognition
of these regions as independent states
not when there are multiple diplomatic
trucks available
and underway that have the ability to
offer peaceful
solutions
mr president
this situation echoes
our history
kenya and almost every african country
was birthed
by the ending of empire
our borders were not of our own drawing
they were drawn in the distant colonial
metropoles of london paris and lisbon
with no regard for the ancient nations
that they cleaved apart
today across the border of every single
african country live our countrymen
with whom we share deep historical
cultural and linguistic bonds
at independence had we chosen to pursue
states on the basis of ethnic racial or
religious homogeneity we would still be
waging bloody wars these many decades
later
instead we agreed that we would settle
for the borders that we inherited
but we would still pursue
continental political economic and legal
integration
rather than form nations that looked
ever backwards into history with a
dangerous nostalgia
we chose to look forward to a greatness
none of our many nations and peoples had
ever
known
we chose to follow the rules of the
organization of african unity and the
united nations charter
not because our border satisfied us but
because we wanted something greater
forged in peace
we believe that all states formed from
empires that have collapsed or retreated
have many peoples in them yearning for
integration with peoples in neighboring
states
this is normal and understandable
after all who does not want to be joined
to their brethren and to make common
purpose with them
however
kenya rejects such a yearning from being
pursued by force
we must complete our recovery from the
embers of dead empires
in a way that does not plunge us back
into new forms of domination
and oppression
we rejected irredentism and expansionism
on any basis including racial ethnic
religious or cultural factors
we read we reject it again today
kenya registers its strong concern and
opposition to the recognition of donetsk
and luhans as independent states
we further strongly condemn the trend in
the last few decades of powerful states
including members of this security
council breaching international law with
little regard
multilateralism lies on its death bed
tonight
it has been assaulted today as it as it
has been by other powerful states in the
recent past
we call on all members to rally behind
the secretary general
in asking him to rally us all to the
standard that defends multilateralism
we also call on him to bring his good
officers to bear to help the concerned
parties resolve this situation by
peaceful means
let me conclude mr president by
reaffirming kenya's respect for the
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
his statement i give the floor to the
permanent representative of ghana
thank you very much mr president
and i would also begin by first of all
thanking
usg rosemary dicarlo for her briefing to
the council
mr president the decision by the russian
federation
to recognize the
non-government-controlled regimes of
eastern ukraine
and to send in troops have stunned the
world
ghana deeply regressed the decision of
the russian federation
to turn us back on the minsk agreement
and the dialogue required to address
concerns over the implementation of the
agreement
when ghana joined this organization in
1957
we were under no illusions that the
international order was perfect
however we were convinced and still are
that the principles of sovereign
equality of states
which constitute the basis of this
organization and our multilateral order
is the veritable foundation for a stable
world
we believe that the united nations
represents the best attempt at
maintaining peace across the nations
forging relations and cooperation
between and among our peoples
and holding forth the prospect of a
better tomorrow
it is for this reason that ghana like
many other members of the organization
has solemnly committed itself to uphold
the charter and international law
we believe that through multilateralism
we can improve
cooperation
to make the world a better place for its
citizens
and for generations about unborn
through this organization and our common
actions on principles such as
self-determination within the context
of the united nations
the countries that existed under
conordia rule have been assisted to
become sovereign and politically
independent states
by his sheer convening power
this organization has set out a pathway
for dialogue for all its members
regardless of differences in political
ideology
and encourage the development and
maintenance of friendly relations
by the actions of this organization the
rights of people across the world have
become more respected by their
governments
and they are well being
better guaranteed
mr president
i will be clear
ghana supports the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
the borders of which it joined this
united nations as a bonafide member
we do not support any actions that
violate ukraine's sovereignty
political independence and territorial
integrity
by our principles
ghana does not recognize any entity
outside of the clear arrangements that
have been established by the charter
and the principles of international law
for the recognition of states
as an international community
we have pulled back from many dangerous
scenarios
when logic and reason have prevailed
and on this occasion we re-echo
the voice of the coalition of peace for
restraint by all parties
the sound of war may be loud and the
may be loud
the voice of peace runs deeper
we add restraint on all unsettled but
accepted situations across the globe
and remind member states of the need to
protect the collective security
mechanism
which requires adherence to the core
principles of the charter
and international law
the true test of greatness lies not in
one's ability to use power
but in the capacity to constrain its use
when that would be an obvious choice by
those of a lesser capacity
we hope that within this council
and perhaps outside of it too
we shall find a resolution of the
existing situation in ukraine
and in a manner that does not impair the
mechanisms for peace
while ghana and other african member
states have always held that the use of
the veto power is anachronistic
and counterproductive to the effective
workings of our modern arrangements
for maintaining global peace and
security
that concern has never been rendered
more acute than in situations such as
the one
we now see
even though may be enough for many
occasions to say that we are against the
actions of a member state
that goes against the international
norms
on this occasion we are all required to
do more
in reaffirming our common commitment to
the purposes
and principles of the charter
besides the immediate cost of
instability
all countries including the most
vulnerable in the developing world
may pay a steep price
for the actions that turn over the
situation of the civilian populations in
donetsk and luhansk
we urge all parties to strictly comply
with the tenants of international law
mr president
we may be at the precipice
but we have not fallen over
the path of dialogue and diplomacy still
remains
we will edge the reversal of escalatory
actions
and also invite the secretary general to
renew his good offices
on the situation in the eastern regions
of ukraine
in close coordination with the osce
and all other relevant partners i thank
you mr president
i thank the representative of ghana for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of gabon
thank you president
first of all i would like to thank ms
dicarlo for her briefing
over the last few weeks we have
regularly been called to monitor the
situation on the border between russia
and ukraine
with fears of military action
and then do you see
donetsk and luhansk have sent
signals of
imminent action
president
today russia has announced his decision
to recognize the
sovereignty of the self-declared
republics of donetsk and luhansk this
decision is heavy with consequence
for this
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
and it also undermines
the implementation of the minsk
agreement
which is particularly attached to the
principles of
the
territorial integrity and national
sovereignty
the attack on these essential pillars of
international relations
we call on all parties to
show restraint and to de-escalate
and to adhere to the pacific settlement
of disputes in line with the united
nations charter and encourages them to
use dialogue
and diplomacy to
avoid irreparable damage from the crisis
thank you
i thank the representative of gabon i
now give the floor to the permanent
representative of norway
president
let me also thank usg rosemary de carlo
for her briefing
and through her the secretary general
for today's press statement
we are gathered here this evening
because of the russian federation's
violation of the core principle on which
this organization is built
the sovereign equality of all its
members
norway strongly condemns the decision by
the russian president to recognize the
self-proclaimed people's republic of the
nests and people's republic of luhansk
in eastern ukraine as independent states
recognition of the self-proclaimed
people's republic is a clear violation
of the minsk agreements under which
russia recognizes the non-government
control areas in eastern ukraine as part
of ukraine
the russian federation as signatory of
the minsk agreements and as endorsed by
resolution 20
2202
has made a clear commitment to seek a
peaceful settlement to this conflict
and
recognition of the self-proclaimed
people's republics runs directly
contrary to the work of the normandy
format and the trilateral contact group
towards a negotiated peace
furthermore
russia's actions constitute a clear
violation of international law
it has chosen unilateral action and
military threats rather than diplomacy
and dialogue
norway urges russia as a party to the
conflict to fulfill its commitments to
abide by international law and to return
to the path of diplomacy
russia's continued massive military
buildup in and around ukraine remains an
issue of grave concern
norway urges russia to de-escalate by
withdrawing its military forces from
within ukraine and from the vicinity of
its borders
we commend ukraine's posture a restraint
in the face of continued provocation and
destabilization efforts
russia's decision to deploy forces in
eastern ukraine is unjustified and
irresponsible
as it further increases tension
we are facing the prospect of a war that
would not only threaten europe's
security architecture but would also
lead to unparalleled suffering for the
civilian population
norway calls on russia to strictly
respect and fully adhere to
international humanitarian law
we call upon all parties to protect
civilians including humanitarian
personnel and civilian infrastructure
and to facilitate safe rapid and
unhindered humanitarian access to those
in need in ukraine
president let me conclude by again
reiterating norway's unwavering support
for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
international recognized borders let me
finally recall the principles and
purposes of the u.n charter which are
now under threat by the action of the
russian federation in and around ukraine
thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement i give the floor to the
permanent representative of china
thank you mr president
mr president
china has been paying close attention to
the latest developments of the situation
in ukraine
we fully elaborated on our position at
the previous two meetings of the council
on this topic at present all parties
concerned must exercise restraint
and avoid any action that may fuel
tensions
we welcome and encourage every effort
for a diplomatic diplomatic solution and
call on all parties concerned to
continue dialogue and consultation
and seek reasonable solutions to address
each other's concerns on the basis of
equality and mutual respect
the current situation in ukraine is a
result of
many
complex factors
china always makes its own position
according to the merits of the matter
itself
we believe that all countries should
solve international disputes
by peaceful
means in line with the purposes and
principles of the uncharted i thank you
mr president
i thank the representative of china
for his statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
russian federation
distinguished colleagues
we've just now heard a number of highly
emotional statements
categorical assessments and far-reaching
conclusions
related to the signing today by russia's
president of decrees recognizing the
laganska and nietzsche people's
republics
i'll lead the direct verbal assaults
against this uh unanswered now it's
important to focus on how to avoid war
and how to force ukraine to stop the
shelling and provocations against nyetsk
and lugansk
from the statements of a number of our
colleagues one may get the impression
that russia's recognition of the lpr and
the dpr took place suddenly
for no reason at all
of course that's not the case
it should be remembered that the dpr and
the lpr declared their independence from
ukraine
back in 2014.
but we only recognize them now despite
the higher level of support for doing so
both in the republics themselves and in
russian society from the very beginning
at the time
the hope went out that the ukrainian
maiden regime would think again and
would stop talking to their own citizens
in the east in the language of canons
and shooting and threats and shelling
time and again we firmly asked kiev to
listen to the aspirations of
the people living in donbas and the
russian-speaking residents of the
country to respect their entirely
legitimate desire to use their mother
tongue and to teach their children in
that language and also to honor the
memories of those who liberated the land
from fascists rather than those who
fought on the side of fascists and had a
hand in the killing of hundreds of
thousands thousands of people during the
second world war
after
ukrainian military adventures butted up
against the determination of the people
of donetsk against to defend their lands
the minsk agreements were signed and the
package of measures was adopted
with the aim of implementing it
there was once again hope for peace and
that the maidan authorities would be
sensible having exhausted the desire to
um submerge dunyes and lugansk in blood
there was a particularly great amount of
hope invested in the election in 2019 of
a new president of ukraine
who promised at long last to establish
peace in donbass
however those who hoped that the
ukrainian authorities would take a
peaceful stance were unfortunately
mistaken kiev not only very quickly
returned to its bellicose rhetoric and
continued the shelling of civilians
but also did everything it could to
sabotage and ultimately destroy the
minsk
agreements and most importantly here is
the flat refusal of kiev to speak
directly with the representatives of
donetsk and lugansk despite the fact
that this requirement is a central
structural element of the package of
measures
an unambiguous confirmation of an
unwillingness to engage in that dialogue
is something we've heard repeatedly from
ukrainian leaders in the last few days
including from the permanent
representative of ukraine during the
security council meeting that we
convened on the 17th of february to
discuss the implementation of the minsk
agreements
after that it became clear once and for
all that ukraine did not intend to
implement the minsk agreements and i
would like to recall
and remind my colleagues on the security
council that in all other conflicts
be it libya syria or yemen
we all demand and call for direct
dialogue between the parties to the
conflict
and it's only
in ukraine for example the ukraine that
is for some reason an exception to this
rule
from some statements today one may
understand that a number of our
colleagues are ready to bury the minsk
agreements
however i would like to remind you that
when the minsk agreements were concluded
the lpr and the dpr had already declared
their independence
the fact that russia today recognized
that
in no way changes the make up of the
parties to the minsk agreements because
russia is not a party to the minsk
agreements we have repeatedly declared
this
and in so doing in this regard nothing
has changed
it's another matter that the minsk
agreements part of the provisions of
which were supposed to be implemented
way back in 2015
have long openly been openly sabotaged
by ukraine with the backing of our
western colleagues and today we can see
that many colleagues want to um sign up
to the idea that the minsk agreements
are dead but that's not the case
and kiev is still bound to implement
them
we remain open to diplomacy
for a diplomatic solution
however allowing
a new bloodbath in the donbass is
something we do not intend to do
unfortunately we are forced to note the
extremely negative role played in all of
this by our western colleagues led by
the usa
instead of forcing kiev to implement its
obligations they have merely been openly
egging ukraine on repeating the
meaningless
mantra that's the obligations under the
minsk agreement are not being
implemented by russia which as we've
repeatedly underscored is not even a
party to the minsk agreements
moreover while uh for the last few weeks
already whipping up unfounded panic
around the allegedly impending russian
invasion of ukraine our western
colleagues
have been unashamedly cramming weapons
into the country sending instructors
there essentially nudging the ukrainians
who have
concentrated uh 120 000 strong military
contingent along the contact line
towards an armed provocation against
donbass
the joint efforts of the western ukraine
have inflated an air bubble that simply
had to burst
in the past weekend there's been a sharp
increase in the intensity of ukrainian
shelling in of residential areas of lpr
and dpr and the um
100 uh 1 600 shells have been shown
civilians have been killed the territory
of the republics has been penetrated by
subversive groups who have carried out
or tried to carry out sabotage of
critical infrastructure
as i already said there are casualties
from among the civilian population
the lpr and dpr have declared general
mobilization
it's in russia and not ukraine
that refugees have flooded too over the
last few days the number of evacuated
women old people and children has
reached around 60 000
people and russia is hosting them and
providing them with conditions for them
to be housed and supported
there has also been shelling of some
towns and villages on russian territory
near the border zone and so it has
become clear that donbass is on the
brink of a new ukrainian military
adventure as was already the case in
2014 and 2015.
the russian president heeded the opinion
of parliamentarians and members of the
russian security council and you know
the rest a detailed statement from our
head of state about the reasons of this
decision that has been taken was
broadcast in detail by all the world's
leading media
today it's true we have heard an open
distortion of what the president was
talking about in his statement about
history and the genesis of this
situation and about the fact that he
allegedly said that he wants to
reconstruct the russian empire
distinguished colleagues
i would like to call upon our western
colleagues to think twice to set
emotions to one side and not to make the
situation worse no one other than you
can hold back the militaristic plans of
kiev and force it to stop the shelling
and provocations against the lugansk and
yes people's republics who in these new
conditions which in these new conditions
could have extremely dangerous
consequences in accordance with the
agreements that were signed today and on
the basis of their uh requests from the
republic peacekeeping functions on their
territories will be carried out by the
armed forces of the russian federation
distinguished colleagues in conclusion i
would like to note
that in today's statement most of you
did not find any place for the more than
4 million of residents of donbass
it's as
though you've been counseling out their
fates from your statements from 2014
generally um calling them pro-russian
separatists
at the same time
we decided that the illegal coup in 2014
and then he wanted to discuss with the
new authorities how their rights would
be upheld that was all they wanted to do
in the last few days
with the sharp identification in
military
activity from the ukrainian army along
the contact line the lives of hundreds
of thousands of women children and
elderly persons have once again as in
2014 and 2015
turned up ended up under real threat and
the main aim of our decision was to
protect and
preserve those people and that is more
important than all of your threats thank
you
i resume my function as president of the
council
i now give the floor to the permanent
representative of ukraine
distinguished members
of the security council
under secretary
it is with
an ease that i will now remove my musk
and it is not because of the
corbid virus
we are all vaccinated
there are vaccines for coverage
it is because of the virus
that has so far no vaccine
the virus that hit
the united nations
and the virus that is spread by the
kremlin
the delegation of ukraine has requested
this urgent meeting to draw the
attention of the security council
to the illegal
and illegitimate decision
by the president of the russian
federation
to recognize
the occupied parts
of the nest and lugansk
regions of ukraine
a so-called danisk and lugansk people's
republics
today the entire membership of the
united nations is under attack
under attack by the country
that occupied
the membership
of the security council in 1991 by
passing the u.n charter
the country that occupied parts of the
territory of georgia
in 2008
the country that occupied parts of
ukraine in 2014
as stated by the president of ukraine
vladimir zelinsky
following the urgent meeting of the
national security and defense council of
ukraine
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine have been
and will remain
unchangeable regardless of any
statements and actions by the russian
federation
ukraine anakivakali qualifies the recent
actions by the russian federation as
violation of sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
the political leadership of the russian
federation shall be a full
responsibility
for the outcomes of the decision taken
recognition of the occupied parts of the
dynasty and lugansk regions of ukraine
may be considered as unilateral
withdrawal by russia from the means
agreements
and
well as its
disregard
of the decisions taken
in the framework of the normandy fall
this step undermines peaceful efforts
and ruins the existing negotiating
frameworks
by the decisions adopted today and those
that may be adopted tomorrow
russia legalizes the presence of its
troops
which have actually been in the occupied
areas of donbass since
2014.
a country that has fueled the war for
eight years is not able to maintain
peace
as it claims
what will happen next
we want peace
and we are consistent in our actions
today the ministry of foreign affairs of
ukraine has sent a request
on the basis of the budapest memorandum
to the guarantors of security of ukraine
demanding immediate consultations
the meeting of the yuan security council
and the special meeting of the oec have
been initiated
we insist on the full-fledged operations
of the oec smm to prevent provocations
and further escalation
an emergency summit of normandy 4 has
been requested
we expect from our partners clear and
efficient steps of support
it is critical to see now who is our
true friend and partner
who is on the side of the iran charter
and who will be who and who will
continue to deter russia by wards only
we are committed to a political
diplomatic settlement
and do not succumb to provocations
in accordance with article 51 of the
charter ukraine has the inherent right
to individual and collective
self-defense
we are committed to a peaceful and
diplomatic path
and we will stay firmly on it
we are on our land
we are not afraid of anything
or anyone
we owe nothing to anyone
and we will not give away anything to
anyone
there should be no doubts whatsoever
because it is not february 2014
it is february 2022.
another country
another army
one goal is peace
peace in ukraine peace in europe
global peace
excellencies
we must do all we can to make sure that
the problem of the bus is resolved
through implementation of the minsk
agreements
that was set here in the security
council chamber just four days ago
said by the russian deputy foreign
minister in the chair of the president
of the council with a reference to
president putin
president putin who has taken a decision
that we discussed today
as a threat to the rules-based order to
the u.n charter
in particular article 2 of the charter
as well as to international peace
and security
peace and security that the council has
been
comfort a primary responsibility to
maintain under the article 24
of the u.n charter
and in accordance of the
with the article 39 the security council
shall make recommendations or decide
what measures shall be taken to maintain
or restore international peace and
security
the delegation of ukraine
requested security council members to
exercise the above duties
we invite the russian federation
to reread again and again
carefully
today's statement
where the secretary general
considered the decision of the russian
federation
to be a violation
of territorial integrity
and sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles
of the charter of the united nations and
i thank the secretary general for this
powerful statement
in conclusion i would like to reiterate
that it remains up to russia
to abandon its long-lasting strategy on
ukraine
based on threat and use of
use of force against the territorial
integrity or political independence of
my country
and re-engage in what we all have
committed to
fundamental principles of peaceful
relations enshrined
in the u.n charter
we demand from russia
to cancel the decision
on recognition
and return to the table
of negotiations
we condemn
the order to deploy
additional russian occupation troops
in the territories of ukraine
we demand immediate and complete very
verifiable withdrawal of the occupation
troops
dear members of the security council
the united nations is sick
that's a matter of fact
it's been hid by the
virus spread by the kremlin
will it succumb to this virus
it is in the hands of the membership
today the kremlin copy-pasted word by
word the decree on georgia of 2008
word by word
copy
paste it
copy paste it
no creativity whatsoever
the copying machine in kremlin works
very well who is the next among the
members of the united nations
the question is open
i thank you
yeah
i as the president of the security
council i'm obliged to say this i thank
the representative of ukraine for his
statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of germany
thank you mr president
i start by thanking under secretary
general rosemarie dicarlo for her
briefing
mr president only four days after our
last meeting
this council meets again to discuss the
situation in ukraine
on thursday there was consensus in the
security council that the minsk
agreements reached this council
unanimously endorsed by its resolution
2202
need to be implemented including by the
russian federation
today we are confronted with the very
opposite from russia president putin's
decision to recognize the separatist
self-declared people's republics in
eastern ukraine
is not only a blatant breach of security
council resolution 2202
but also of basic principles enshrined
in the u.n charter
it is another flagrant and deliberate
violation of ukraine's territory
integrity after the illegal annexation
of crimea and the instigation and
fueling of the armed conflict in eastern
ukraine
since 2014
russia has repeatedly insisted it was
not party to the conflict
today it unmasks itself and shows that
it always has been
mr president my government condemns
russia's violation of the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine in
the strongest possible terms
with our allies and partners we will
take firm and adequate measures in
response to russia's breach of
international law that will have serious
economic political and geostrategic
consequences and i call on all u.n
member states to join us in condemning
russia's actions of today today's
decision comes in the context of an
unprecedented
buildup of russian forces around ukraine
over the last weeks and months
these forces seem poised to attack we
have seen a flare-up along the line of
contact over the last days and efforts
that appear to fabricate a pretext for
russian attack moreover russia has
declared its readiness to deploy troops
in eastern ukraine
the u.n charter is crystal clear
it
unequivocally prohibits the threat of
force against the territory integrity
and political independence of states
the current russian force deployment
around ukraine can only be considered as
a further threat against ukraine's
territorial integrity as a whole
mr president president i call on russia
to live up to its obligations as a
permanent member of this this council
and i urge russia to immediately revoke
today's decisions and recommit to the
minsk agreements
and in line with the normandy4 and what
was agreed on russia must not cross the
international recognized borders of
ukraine moreover russia must immediately
withdraw its troops from the regions
bordering with ukraine and russia and
belarus and i call on russia to recommit
to the rules-based security architecture
in europe which has been built over
decades
russia's decisions have put this order
under serious strain
we call upon russia to instead return to
the path of diplomacy
of shedding instead of shedding further
blood and germany will spare no
diplomatic effort in this regard
while steadfastly standing by ukraine
its territorial integrity and
sovereignty and the ukrainian people
thank you
i thank the representative of germany
for her statement
there are no more names inspired on the
list to speak as the meeting is
adjourned